hay que encontrarla porque se necesitan
unos recursos para poder sostener los
programas sociales del país está en una
situación crítica hoy salieron los datos
de pobreza el 42.5 por ciento de la
población colombiana no tiene el ingreso
suficiente para comer tres veces al día
para pagar una vivienda y para pagar los
servicios públicos entonces con una
situación tan grave lo social se
necesita reforzar la política se
necesita darle un sustento un apoyo a
las familias y es de ahí de donde se
justifica la necesidad de una reforma
tributaria no la que presentó
originalmente el gobierno demasiado
ambiciosa en mi opinión pero sí una
reforma que de unos recursos adicionales
bueno justamente recursos por ejemplo
para cubrir el déficit fiscal del país
que sigue siendo muy alto que se puede
hacer para subsanar este déficit sin
ahogar aún más a las familias cuando
están justamente atravesando la crisis
económica generada por el coi 19 hay que
proteger a la clase media no podemos
poner de la clase media a pagar los
subsidios de las personas que están en
pobreza deben ser los colombianos con
una mayor capacidad económica como se
logra eso
manteniendo el impuesto de renta de las
empresas en el 33% pidiéndole un
esfuerzo adicional a los colombianos que
tienen patrimonios de más de 5 mil
millones de pesos y pidiendo al mismo
tiempo un aumento en el impuesto a los
dividendos que lo reciben el 1% más rico
de la población colombiana entonces
vamos a tener que ser solidarios buscar
el apoyo de las personas en mejor
condición y mayor capacidad económica
para conseguir los recursos que permitan
sostener los programas sociales pues
agradecemos al doctor mauricio cárdenas
ex ministro